oui monsieur le Président Madame la
première Mini chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur en 2018 la
France refusait d'accueillir les 629
migrants de l'Aquarius la même année à
l'Assemblée générale des Nations unies
le président de la République disait
préféré une mobilité internationale
choisie et non subit au risque de faire
monter les extrêmes on connaît la suite
de l'histoire vendredi dernier manuel
Macron donnait l'ordre d'accueillir 230
migrants de l'océan Viking à Toulon
madame la ministre la France ne veut pas
accueillir toute la misère du monde dans
notre pays beaucoup de personnes
français étrangers assimilés en la plus
grande difficulté pour se nourrir se
loger se soigner demain pour se chauffer
bref pour survivre on accueillant
l'océan Viking vous confondez
humanitaire et appelle d'air en
accueillant l'océan Viking vous faites
le jeu des passeurs sauvez des vies en
péril est une priorité mais les bateaux
de passeurs doivent être envoyés dans
les ports de départ il est urgent que la
France reprenne le contrôle de ses
frontières il est urgent qu'il y ait une
refonte de la politique d'immigration au
niveau européen autrement vous
continuerez à dénaturer la France et à
mettre les Français en danger
oui il existe un lien entre immigration
et insécurité dame la ministre combien
faudra-t-il de Bataclan de caramel de
massacres Nice de Lola pour que vous
puissiez enfin
la mesure du destin qui se joue sous les
yeux
qu'attendez-vous chez les accueillir
sont de l'isote ne veulent pas et pour
expulser tous ceux qui n'ont pas
vocation à être sur notre sol nation